[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to
the shitless roundup where we round up
all the tweety tweets and the training
trends of the day as you know
as you know there's a lot a lot of news
going on a lot of stuff is trending on
twitter let's start with the uh at the
profile at the timeline here
zoom out
a little bit
let's see let's refresh here there's a
lot of stuff i retweeted
i want to i want to get to some of this
stuff um spread around the link today
you're going to want to spread this link
around
at the top um so that everyone can go
watch dakota's reaction in the second
hour at the top of the second hour um
fun fact though fun fact of today
fun fact rush limbaugh
has been drug free for a whole year
congrats rushbo
congrats buddy you've been you've been
drug free for a whole [ __ ] year want
a piece of [ __ ] oh look [ __ ] rush
limbaugh
[ __ ] em
well maybe we'll play that later
i i really so
let's get back on this wrestling ball
thing
let's do this let's do this part really
quick all right not really quick we're
probably gonna take a few minutes on
this
a lot of people a lot of people know who
wrestling ball is that vile piece of
[ __ ] a lot of people don't know all the
stuff that he said and how he did his
radio show um i used to listen and and
and stay with me here i used to listen
to wrestling ball for years almost all
three hours and when i would work uh
years ago i would be in the car a lot of
times driving around and so i would
listen to wrestling ball now i would
vehemently disagree with 99. 100 of what
he said
and i would be screaming screaming at
the radio the entire time so that was
like my practice for this show for
[ __ ] years is to yell and scream at
the radio while rush limbaugh was
talking um he would do three hours of
vile [ __ ] propaganda every single day
right ring propaganda every single
[ __ ] day now there's a lot of
significant things about rush limbaugh
okay and the reason why we're at where
we're at in the world today and in this
country specifically with trumpism
he is really the birth of this trumpism
stuff
you know to to un
un
undo
the the thin veiling of fascism in this
country for years uh conservatives quote
unquote would thin bail fascism with
things like debt deficits you know
that's sort of [ __ ] and then it
worked into when barack obama became
president it became the tea party type
[ __ ]
um obstruction and then it became
trumpism so there's been a lot of
[ __ ] br rebranding over the years of
this right-wing fascism in this country
this american talibanism as we know it
today
uh where they're running amok these
[ __ ] we even have politicians making
commercials talking about uh how guns
are are made we have gun rights to kill
other politicians in the government and
to overthrow the government like you
were running for the government you dumb
[ __ ]
people they really are [ __ ]
boneheaded they don't even know they're
domestic terrorists and they're domestic
terrorists like the guy down and
wherever the [ __ ] uh giving some kind of
commercial where he's shooting uh mark
kelly after mark kelly's wife
uh and um was [ __ ] shot at a
political event
in the face because of some deranged
person who would was believing [ __ ]
[ __ ] information on the internet he
was radicalized
by a bunch of dumb [ __ ] on the internet
to go shoot and try to kill a politician
this is all this is all in in this is
all part of the plan with wrestling ball
right to cause chaos that's the whole
point
to to leak propaganda into the minds of
right-wing americans and to convince
right-wing americans and pull them
farther and farther further right extrem
making them extremist
that's the whole point now ruslan ball
became less and less relevant over the
years here's why
in the in the late 80s in the early 90s
when rush limbaugh started his radio
show there wasn't a such thing as social
media right our new cycle was a hell of
a lot longer it was long like like
maybe 48 hour news cycle right and then
um soon into the 90s we got to a 24-hour
news cycle right ruslan ball came on the
radio
all across the country on am stations
and then later in fm stations and one of
the biggest [ __ ] pushers of ruslan
ball was cumulus broadcasting they're
still one of the biggest pushers of
right-wing propaganda today
cumulus broadcasting go look it up i'm
not making this [ __ ] [ __ ] up
wrestling ball would come on the radio
at noon eastern every day the reason why
rush limb ball was on at noon eastern
for three hours every single day in the
local am stations and that's the key
here
that was that that was the secret sauce
he was a local voice he was a local
voice on the local radio station
syndicated right
it would pump his message into millions
of mines of
americans mostly those who are who are
pre-programmed to be right wing in the
first place
now the reason why ruslan ball was on at
noon eastern every single day
was to make sure that those people who
were gonna go home and watch the local
news and the national news at six
o'clock right you guys remember this
there used to not be [ __ ] facebook
they used not be twitter you you went
home and you watched the news at night
the evening news now there was cnn and
stuff but not everyone had cable at that
point and not everyone was wrapped in
this 24-hour news cycle now we got like
a five-second news [ __ ] cycle
what rush limbaugh's
whole [ __ ] goal
with his radio show was was to make sure
that he programmed people
that when they watched the news that
night they knew how to feel about the
news
right because that's all it's about it's
not about facts it's not about real [ __ ]
it's it's not it's not about being
tethered to reality it's about how am i
supposed to feel
about the news you know that was the
whole mainstream media
you know acting like the media is a
left-wing operation get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] us on the left know
that the media isn't a left-wing for
[ __ ] sure
for [ __ ] sure we know the media isn't
[ __ ] left-wing the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] but rush limbaugh's whole
goal is to make sure that those folks
out there in this country that were
supposed to be right-wing that were
supposed to vote republican that were
part of the gqp
make sure that they were pre-programmed
when they watched the national news and
their local news headlines
when they got their paper in the evening
at the grocery store before they went
home before they listened to the
national news before they had a chance
the idea was to make sure that they
pre-programmed exactly how they were
supposed to feel about it exactly how
they were supposed to interpret it that
way in the morning when they went back
to the office went back to the school
went back to their community
went back to work they could stand there
and they could propagate his message and
his [ __ ] and the way you're supposed
the way you're supposed to feel where
you're supposed to feel about the news
because that's all this is these [ __ ]
snowflakes don't have any kind of
tethering to reality
because they're [ __ ] snowflakes truth
is their [ __ ] enemy democracy is
their [ __ ] enemy that's why we see
the gqp is supporting russia
because russia's whole goal here is to
question and doubt democracy that's what
putin wants
putin doesn't want a hot war putin
doesn't want to have to [ __ ] force
the american government nato to be to
apply sanctions to him
but he may have to because democracy is
his enemy
democracy is always a tyrant there's
always a fascist enemy it's always a
totalitarian regime's enemy
that's it
that's what it is
you can say whatever you want about the
war in ukraine and the border and why
they're doing what they're doing putin
is testing democracy just like rush
limbaugh did for years and years on the
radio that [ __ ]
they don't want democracy they want
fascism fascism is not democracy it's
not it won't be it never be
and that's the thing we need to make
sure that all americans know here
i'm gonna talk a little bit more about
this today i had a conversation with
someone yesterday a former republican
and they're they're they're sick and
tired of the gqp [ __ ] as well
so we'll talk about that later on in the
hour
but i think it's very significant
that we talk about rush limbaugh today
because
this this
misinformation disinformation this
right-wing propaganda didn't just start
with social media
l rush bow here
that's what they used to call him l rush
bow
[ __ ] that guy
mego dittos to him being dead [ __ ] him
this country is way better off without
that son of a [ __ ] having a microphone
way better off
now because we have free speech in this
country sometimes sometimes it takes
someone
to kick the old bucket to get rid of
their voice
and i'm not i'm not much of a
superstitious person and i'm not much of
a religious person
but go grin reaper
[Laughter]
in this case [ __ ] him
we should all be happy in this country
that wrestling ball does not have a
microphone whatever way that that took
him dying from cancer that piece of [ __ ]
after he propagated for years that
cigarettes don't cause cancer [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him that [ __ ] lying bio racist
homophobic piece of [ __ ]
okay
maybe enough on rush
all right let's go back to the timeline
doo doo doo doo